THESE ORDERS THE SENATE TO MAKE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE THE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WORLD IN
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN
THE CAPITOL BUILDING TODAY TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WITH
ADMITTED NUMBERS THE PUBLIC TO
TWO HEARING ROOMS EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE TO SUPPORT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
BUSINESS BUT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE THREE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN OH FIVE SIX NINE
ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND ARE. ARE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMEDY OF THE PROFIT BY
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU TO A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME HE WILL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOT READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU. AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM- DURING THIS
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEDIAN SERVICER HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WELL EVERY
EFFORTS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE
THE HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT
A HEARING AND IS CLOSE. TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
DISPENSARY JUSTIN TO THE NEW
USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENTS OF ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
RIGHT WE HAD TO WE HAD TO BILLS
ON OUR AGENDA TODAY ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN FIVE NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY. HAS
BEEN PULLED AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR FROM THIS HEARING.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON
THE REMAINING BILL LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MISTER
CONSULT IF YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GLAZER PRESENT PRESENT
GLAZER PRESENT NIELSEN
HERTZBERG LEYVA YOUR BRAVERY
HERE NEWMAN YEAH NEWMAN HERE
ALL RIGHT WE DO A QUORUM AND
I'VE BEEN INFORMED THAT THE
VICE CHAIR WHO'S GOING TO BE A
LITTLE BIT LATE THIS MORNING AS
OKAY DOES BEGINNING THIS
HEARING IN HIS ABSENCE AND
HEALTHY HOPEFULLY FOR JOINING
US TODAY. RIGHT THE FIRST BILL
AND ONLY FILL UP ON OUR DOCKET
TODAY A SENATE BILL THIRTY FIVE
FILE ITEM ONE SENATOR AMBER
WELCOME AND YOU CAN PRESENT
YOUR BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IN MEMBERS- I'M HAPPY TO
BE BACK HERE PRESENTING SENATE
BILL THIRTY FOUR AS AMENDED THE
AMENDED SIMPLY ALIGN THE
DEADLINE FOR GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATES TO COMPLY WITH THE
EXISTING TAX RETURN DISCLOSURE
LAW WITH REGULAR CANDIDATE
FILING DEADLINES IT ALSO
PROVIDES A NOTIFICATION PROCESS
IN A CURE PERIOD FOR CANDIDATES
TO REMEDY ANY DEFICIENCIES WITH
RESPECT TO THE SUBMISSION OF
THEIR TAX RETURN. WITH ME HERE
TO TESTIFY IS MISTER GARRAS THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY OF STATE FOR
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS ON THE
SECTOR'S. STATES OFFICE STATED
CALIFORNIA. I YOU CENTER ON
PROGRAMMING AS WE THIS TESTS.
BUT PROCESS THAT. WE'RE GONNA
ALLOW EACH SIDE TO PRESENT- IN
EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME TO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH-
AFTER THAT WE'LL GO TO ANYONE
ELSE WITH WHICH YOU TO TESTIFY
HERE IN THE IN THE CAPITAL OR
ON OUR PHONE LINES. WHERE THEY
CAN PROVIDE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE AND THAT'S ALL WE WILL
HEAR. FROM THEM AT THAT TIME.
SO MISTER ERIC GARRIS I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE ON THE LINE
AND YOU'RE WELCOME TO PROVIDE
YOUR TESTIMONY. MORE MISTER
MEMBERS- I THINK OUT THERE
PRETTY WELL FROM THE BILL- I
WON'T TAKE UP MUCH OF YOUR TIME
AND IF THEY I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION CRITICAL
AMENDMENTS ARE YOUR SUPPORT
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER GARRISON-
WHAT WE'RE GONNA THAT YOU HAD
TO JUST A SINGLE WITNESS RIGHT
A CENTER NUMBER OF OKAY SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO- FIRST IN
THE HEARING ROOM ANYONE HERE
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF SB
THIRTY FIVE. WHITE SEA NINE
WILL GO TO A REMOTE- HEARING
SPACE- ROOM TWENTY FORTY ANYONE
THERE. SEE NO ONE THERE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES- MODERATOR
IF YOU ASK ANYONE WHO WISHED TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF SB THIRTY
FIVE TO PLEASE SO INDICATE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE THREE IN.
THE QUEUE OUR FIRST LINE.
COMMENT IS NINE FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN THE
THREE FOUR MENDOZA AYE OPPOSED
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT OUR
MODERATOR NEXT NEXT FULLER
PLEASE. WE'RE ON THE SUPPORT
SIDE IF YOU CAN REMIND THEM
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY FIVE FIRST. NINE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TEN OF MY IN
COMMITTEE IS THIS THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE THE PHONES DON'T ALWAYS
WORK I'M CALLING TO OPPOSE
THIRTY FIVE AM I IN THE RIGHT
PLACE YES YOU ARE JUST PROVIDE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION
IN YOUR POSITION HAS ALREADY
BEEN EDUCATE. BUT AM I IN THE
RIGHT PLACE BECAUSE THE- LADY
BEFORE ME WAS A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSED MAYBE THE PUBLIC IS
CONFUSED. MAYBE THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND YOUR SYSTEM. ALL
RIGHT MAYBE IT'S BEEN SET UP
THAT WAY IF YOU WANT TO PROVIDE
YOUR NAME YOU CAN'T IF NOT
WE'LL GO ON TO THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THE NINE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR BURKE THIS
IS TONY TRIP GUERO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT S. B.
THREE FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY
TWELVE YEAR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SHERRY
MARSH IN I'M GOING TO OPPOSE
BILL THIRTY FIVE DEMOCRATS ARE
COUNTING ON. AND WE FEEL THAT
THIS BILL OKAY THANK YOU MA'AM
WE WERE DOING SUPPORT RIGHT AT
THIS POINT BUT WE HAVE RECORDED
YOUR OPPOSITION POSITION THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
MEXICANS COLOR PLEASE. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN Q. OKAY WILL DO ONE
FINAL CALL ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
FIVE TO PLEASE INDICATE ONE
LAST TIME MODERATOR AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO THE OPPOSITION SIDE.
THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT GREAT THANK
YOU MODERATOR OKAY WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO OPPOSITION NOW DO SB
THIRTY FIVE. WILL BEGIN HERE IN
OUR HEARING ROOM IS ANYONE
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. HERE IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE C. NINE WILL GO TO A
REMOTE. MEETING ROOM I SEE NO
ONE THERE IT WILL GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES. MODERATE WOULD YOU
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTY FIVE TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMONSENSE.
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE TIME. ONE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THE BRIDGE LINE.
TEN PLEASE PROVIDE A CLIENT
POSITION OF SB THIRTY FIVE
NINE. I'M GOOD I GOT TO THE
RIGHT PLACE BECAUSE IT DIDN'T
SEEM LIKE YOU WERE PROPERLY RE
ROUTING PEOPLE AND PEOPLE ARE
CONFUSED BY THEIR SYSTEM YOUR
SYSTEM AND WE'RE SET UP WITH
THAT THIS IS NOT USER FRIENDLY
AND YOU NEED TO CHANGE YOUR
WAYS THIS IS A WE THE PEOPLE.
NOT AYE THE GOVERNMENT. I
OPPOSE THIS BILL IN CASE YOU
WERE WONDERING. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY AND ONE TWELVE
YES YOU ARE. OKAY GREAT MY NAME
IS JANELLE ARCH IN I'M CALLING-
TO OPPOSE THE BILL THIRTY FIVE
AND SO THAT THIS WOULD EXCLUDE-
CANNOT USE YOUR CAMERA TO THE
POLITICAL RATES FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THEN I THINK ARE BUT ALSO- NOT
TO GIVE JANET A TIMELY. MANNER
TO IMPLEMENT PAPERWORK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND HAVE A
WONDERFUL DAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
I WILL CONSIDER THAT TO BE THE
SECOND LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
SO WE'LL JUST ASK THOSE THAT
REMAIN TO JUST GET THEIR NAME
AND AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
ON THE BILL SO- MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU'RE RIGHT TO CUT THE
PEOPLE OFF WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY I DON'T HAVE TIME
TO SPEAK AND YOUR OWN CUT OFF
IS. CALLER PLEASE ONLY
ARBITRARY DESERVE TIME DON'T
YOU CAN MODERATOR LASER COLOR
YOU'VE GOT ME OFF. I JUST A
WRITER NEXT NOW CALLER PLEASE.
I THINK THAT RECORD THAT IS HER
THIRD TIME THAT'S OKAY THERE IN
OPPOSITE. SINCE THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
OKAY WE'LL GIVE IT ONE LAST
FINAL ATTEMPT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION SB THIRTY FIVE ON
THE PHONE LINES PLEASE SO
INDICATE AND THAT WILL BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION. RIGHT
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A NINE
FIFTEEN QUEUING AGAIN. SINCE.
CONDITIONS ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THANKS FIFTEEN I CAN READ YOU
THE FIRST AMENDMENT ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU LET ME READ
THE FOR HAVE YOU CAN YOU CAN
CUT HER OFF ANYBODY ELSE IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER LINE OKAY TERRIFIC
WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I SB THIRTY FIVE
BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY MEMBER
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
NOW WITH THE BILL. CASSIE NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS CENTER ON
OVER THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK IN
THIS SPACE AND- CREATE- THE-
EARNESTNESS IN WHICH YOU ARE
ADVANCING THIS GOOD POLICY
CHANGE- ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
SAY IN CLOSING. JUST RATHER
SURPRISED THAT. THERE'S A
PARTICULAR LANGUAGE THAT NEEDS
TO BE USED ON THIS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SPEAKING CURTIN SAID
EARLIER WAS THAT AGREEMENT THAT
WOULD BE THE MOTIONS OF THE DAY
AS- AND WITH THAT THE- HE
CLOSED CENTER NUMBER. OKAY WILL
CALL THE ROLL. SB THIRTY FIVE
THE MOTION IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS TO BE CONCURRED AND
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE NIELSEN.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA
LEVER BY NEWMAN NEWMAN HI OKAY
IT HAS THE VOTES TO GET OUT-
WE'RE GONNA SEE IF SENATOR
NIELSEN IS GONNA MAKE IT HERE
THIS MORNING SO WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW
MINUTES- AND THEN WE JUST
MENTIONED THAT I WANTED TO
THANK THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE O
ELECTIONS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS REPORT TO US AND WE
ONE INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION SO WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW
MINUTES MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PROCESS TODAY AND- WILL
SIT CENTER DEALS IS GONNA JOIN
US CHANGES TO. THIS. COMMITTEE
WILL BE IN RECESS. YEAH.
MORNING SO WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLE ON SB
THIRTY FIVE THE BILLS OUT FOR
TWO ZERO AND WITH THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU ALL.